this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by skillshare home to 15
000 classes that could teach you a new
life skill
the first 400 people to sign up using
the link in the description will get a
two-month free trial
world war one was a static grueling war
weapon technology had advanced quickly
but the technology to carry these
weapons lagged behind
resulting in bloody face-offs between
entrenched armies
no battle embodies this ghastly form of
war more than the battle of verdun
on the muse river which was the longest
battle of world war one
lasting 300 days with over one million
casualties
a stalemate where territory was won with
the lives of the men brave enough to
push forward
into the storm of bullets and explosive
shells raining from all directions
26 years later the germans crossed this
same river in a single
day empowered by immense improvements in
motorized vehicles
most notably the tank the germans
created a new form of warfare where
battles were fought and won
before the victim even understood what
was happening with these machines in
your arsenal
trench warfare was obsolete war was no
longer two-dimensional
in one moment you were ducking for cover
anticipating an explosion as the war of
swarming dive bombers filled your ears
the next you're facing a wall of armored
vehicles this of course was the infamous
blitzkrieg which germany employed to
take over the majority of europe with
eerie efficiency
europe would get its first taste of this
lightning war on september 1st
1939 when 1.5 million german troops
invaded poland
the german invasion of poland was a
battle of epic disproportions
duluth dwapha flew ahead armed with
junker 87 stukka dive bombers
which were fitted with horrifying sirens
which were simply high revving
propellers fitted to the landing gear of
the plane
they were designed to cause mass panic
and fear among civilians and enemy
troops alike
they destroyed strategic positions and
caused civilians to flee and interfere
with supply lines softening the border
defenses before the german armored
divisions broke through like a spear
point through inadequate armor
followed by motorized german infantry
who formed a supply column
reinforcing the front line with fuel and
ammunition
never stopping to celebrate always
pushing forward and keeping the pressure
on
any troops that did not retreat fast
enough were encircled and decimated
this pattern was repeated and in a
single week german troops advanced 225
kilometers onto warsaw's doorstep
despite poland mobilizing one million
men to fight back
one famous battle on this first day of
war often mistold
involved a valiant cavalry rush of the
polish army on the german infantry
dispersing them and delaying their
advancement long enough to allow the
polish first rifle battalion to retreat
only then german tanks appeared and
fired upon them forcing the horse units
to retreat
and german propaganda announced the
stupidity of polish commanders sending
cavalry armed with sabers and lances
against armoured vehicles
when in reality they were armed with
anti-tank rifles
which were capable of penetrating 15
millimeters of armor
at 300 meters at 30 degrees the panzer
one and two
used in this battle were vulnerable to
this weapon on september 28th
four weeks after the first shot was
fired the polish capitals surrendered
to the relentless german siege while
russia took the east
this proved the effectiveness of the
blitzkrieg and sent shockwaves through
europe
on may 10 1940 germany launched an
invasion of the low countries of holland
belgium and luxembourg luxembourg with
just 400
infantry and 12 cavalry fell in a single
day
belgium's defense centered around the
iban amal fort with 1
200 men also fell on a single day this
fortress was one of the strongest in the
world
but was created with 2d strategic
maneuvers in mind
it took about 500 german special forces
landing with gliders to disable ibn
amal's major defenses
they removed explosive charges from
nearby bridges ensuring a clear route
for german reinforcements
others landed inside the fort planting
their own explosive charges
and throwing grenades into bunkers and
destroying artillery
where they couldn't overcome defenders
they called for air strikes from stuka
dive bombers
holland despite having advanced warning
of the imminent invasion were caught off
guard by merciless bombing of their
cities by the luftwaffe
followed by the deployment of the 7th
and 22nd airborne divisions
germany now had a direct northern route
into france
the allies were prepared for this threat
and focused their best troops on the
northern border
leaving the heavily fortified border
between germany and france
relatively low manned the invasion of
the low countries was not intended as an
invasion route
it was a diversion and on may 12th the
spearhead of the german blitzkrieg
broke through what was once called the
impenetrable defense of the rough
mountainous and heavily wooded area
of the ardenes quickly enveloping and
trapping the four hundred thousand
allied troops stationed to defend the
assumed invasion from the north
culminating in the battle of dunkirk
where thousands of civilian ships sailed
from britain to save stranded soldiers
a month later on june 22nd france
surrendered to germany
the french were simply not prepared for
the speed and ferocity of this type of
warfare
despite having tanks more than capable
of taking on the german panzers in
one-on-one battle
for example the french s-35 was arguably
the best tank at the outbreak of the war
it had good balance between armor
mobility and firepower
it was more than capable of taking on
the panzer ones and twos
that formed the brunt of the armored
divisions and its forward-facing armor
could even withstand direct hits from
the german heavy tank
the panzer iv where the s35 failed was
its lack of numbers with only 440 built
had the french been prepared and built
enough tanks they could have defeated
the german invasion
the germans were more than aware of this
outclassing of their tanks and led them
into pushing further to create larger
tanks with thicker and thicker armor
and larger and larger guns they pushed
the boundaries and experimented with
gigantic tanks like the panzer 8
which still to this day is the heaviest
fully enclosed
armored fighting vehicle ever built
reallifelord just uploaded a video about
the crazy designs of tanks the germans
came up with
here he is to tell you a little more
about them the panzer 8 mouse weighed
188 tons
over three times heavier than a tire 1
tank its 128 millimeter main gun was
enough to destroy
all allied armored vehicles then in
service at ranges exceeding three and a
half
thousand meters only two were ever built
near the end of the war but the germans
had far
more ambitious plans than even the mouse
tank the lond kreutza p1000
ratta was a super tank designed in 1942
that was planned on weighing 1
000 tons this behemoth would have been
armed with naval artillery and be
equipped with 25 centimeters of hardened
steel armor
it would have had a crew of over 40 men
operating it had it ever been built
but as with most insane nazi engineering
ideas
the lon croitsa remained a blueprint for
the entirety of the war
this wild experimentation could have
been their downfall constant iterations
and improve technology kept production
costs and time high
ultimately germany had some of the most
advanced tanks but too few to take on
what was to come
because the russians were busy building
a staggering secret army of t-34s
this haunting recording of hitler's
normal speaking voice captures his shock
at the sheer number of tanks encountered
on the eastern front
under income
at this stage hitler knew the might of
the german blitzkrieg had met its match
germany had focused so much of their
time trying to create the perfect war
machine
while russia saw how to beat the
blitzkrieg in sheer numbers
determination armor and firepower russia
could build enormous amounts of the t-34
partially because of the insanely huge
factories but also because of the
russian ethos of quantity over quality
russian tanks were crudely constructed
welding was poor
and armored plates rarely fit together a
flaw which the japanese exploited by
throwing molotov cocktails at the tanks
which then dripped flaming fuel onto the
crew the pins that held the track of the
t-34
were not held in place either most tanks
had some form of locking mechanism that
kept the pin in place
but the t-34 pins were free to float to
prevent them from falling out the t-34
simply had a hard stop in the path of
the track that hammered the pins back
into place
as they passed by a crude yet effective
measure to keep the manufacturing time
and cost down
this crude construction did not stop
this tank from being a formidable
opponent
in fact the t-34 is one of the standout
tanks of world war
ii it had heavily sloped armor which
both helped deflect projectiles
but also increased the effective
thickness of the armor thanks to a bit
of trigonometry
if we take the 47 millimeter thick front
hull armor of the t-34
its armor is simply 47 millimeters thick
when vertical
but if we begin to tilt it its effective
thickness equals the original thickness
divided by the sine of the tilt angle
the front hole armor had a slope of 60
degrees
making its effective thickness 94
millimeters double its actual thickness
this combined with the enormous gun
allowed the t-34 to take on any tank on
the battlefield
by the end of the war 8 out of 10 german
soldiers died fighting on the eastern
front
one of the standout battles on the
eastern front if not in the history of
mankind
was the battle of kursk while d-day
stalingrad
the battle of the bulge and the battle
of britain are hailed as the great
turning points of the war
as they should they all pale in
magnitude to the battle of kursk
this battle epitomizes the resilience of
the russian people
kursk sat in the middle of a bulge on
the eastern front
a bulge that needed to be eliminated to
prevent russia from mounting a
counter-offensive on the german's rear
the strategic importance of this battle
was known to both sides
hitler had told heinz gadarian the
mastermind of the german blitzkrieg
that the thought of the battle made him
sick to his stomach every time he
thought about it
russia had dug deep in kursk every
single citizen was involved in the war
effort with near 5 000 kilometers of
trenches circling the city
half a million each of anti-tank and
anti-personnel mines with obstacles torn
with barbed wire
and this was just their passive defense
russia had amassed 1.3 million soldiers
20 000 artillery pieces 3 600 tanks
and 2 600 aircraft this was russia's
last stand
hitler ordered 900 000 soldiers to the
region
drawing men away from the western front
as the allies were not expected to
attack anytime soon
along with ten thousand artillery guns
two thousand seven hundred tanks
and two thousand aircraft this was one
third of germany's remaining military
strength
concentrated in a single area what led
was the largest tank battle in history
and a battle that ultimately blunted the
spearhead of the german blitzkrieg
day after day germany attempted to break
through the russian defense
only to be repelled time after time the
luftwaffe was prevented from gaining air
superiority by the russian air force
while german tanks were crippled by the
combined onslaught of anti-tank mines
infantry artillery fire and the
never-ending barrage of t-34s
all the while partisan citizens to the
rear disrupted the already dodgy supply
lines feeding the german front
this was the last step forward the nazis
took russia had endured the storm
germany would be on the back foot for
the rest of the war and the race towards
berlin between the allies and the
soviets was on
many of you asked me what software i
used to animate these videos and how i
learned
i used a program called adobe after
effects and thought myself how to use it
by watching videos online
these days you can teach yourself pretty
much any skill online and skillshare is
a fantastic place to do it
with professional and understandable
classes that follow a clear learning
curve
skillshare is an online learning
community for creators
with more than 15 000 classes in graphic
design
animation web development photography
video game design and more a premium
membership begins around 10
a month for unlimited access to all
courses but the first 400 people to sign
up with this link
will get a two-month free trial in those
two months you could easily learn the
skills you need to start a new hobby
or business just like i did with this
channel
so ask yourself right now what skill
have you been putting off learning
what project have you been dreaming of
completing but you aren't sure if you
have the skills to do it
why not stare right now and sign up to
skillshare using the link below
you have nothing to lose and a valuable
life skill to gain
as usual if you want to follow me on
instagram twitter facebook or listen to
my new podcast with sam from
wendoverproductions
the links are in the description i'd
also like to thank my patreon supporters
you may have noticed a significant leap
in animation quality this week and
that's thanks to patreon
and mike from mobox graphics mike is an
engineer like me
and a far superior animator all of your
pledges go to employingmike
if we can raise enough on patreon we may
even be able to get mike working on real
engineering full time
to bring you more videos every month
thanks for watching and see you in two
weeks for the next episode of real
[Music]
[Music]
engineering
you